[Music]  hey I'm Fred Rogers in here  it's a beautiful day in this  neighborhood a beautiful day for a  neighbor would you be mine could you be  mine  please vote you be my neighbor  hello neighbor  mr. Rogers I'm here to interview you it  is so nice to meet you okay hold on  mr. Rogers Lloyd please don't want my  childhood this piece will be for an  issue about heroes do you consider  yourself a hero we are trying to get the  world positive ways of dealing with it  feelings  now like what  many things you can do  you can play all the lowest keys on a  piano at the same time  you love broken people  like me  sometimes we have to ask for help and  that's okay  I think the best thing we can do is to  let people know bowling  that each one of them is breakfast  hey mr. Rogers it's a beautiful  neighborhood a beautiful day per  neighbor  please boss to me that was wonderful  [Music]